bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
78 weekend ben ça commence bien ensemble
nous allons revenir sur l'actualité
locale de cette semaine nous
accueillerons également sur le plateau
Samuel Denis directeur du scarabé de la
verrière mais tout de suite nous ouvrons
cette émission avec le comédien Arnaud
de samère de passage jeudi soir à la
salle jacqu brelle de Montini le
Bretonneux pour son spectacle chose
promise nous l'avons rencontré pendant
les répétitions
ARN Sam on ne te présente plus tu joues
ce soir à la S jabrelle de montinis un
peu un retour aux sources exactement
exactement après des spectacles
d'improvisation que j'ai joué ah il y a
presque 10 ans voilà je reviens vraiment
avec plaisir sur cette scène alors ça
fait quoi justement de revenir IR tu
retrouves tu penses retrouver des gens
que tu connais que tu as connu alors non
non parce que parce que c'est c'est un
petit peu trop loin ça c'est un peu trop
loin tout ça
mais voilà moi je suis quelqu'un
qui je suis attaché à voilà aux endroits
où j'ai vécu je suis un peu nostalgique
comme garçon donc je suis très content
de revenir à Montini j ai vécu presque
10 ans
donc je suis très heureux alors là tu
vas nous présenter enfin tu vas
présenter public en tout cas ton
spectacle est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
retrouver learnaud de sa mère que bah
les gens voient à l'écran ah ben oui
parce que parce que ce que je fais à la
télé c'est c'est dans la c'est dans la
LI la lignée de de de ce qu'on a écrit
pour le spectacle alors le spectacle ne
comporte pas de sketch fait à la télé
j'ai j'ai j'ai pas repris de sketch de
la télé dans dans le spectacle mais mais
le style est voilà le style est le mien
c'est le même donc normalement les gens
doivent pas être déçus a priori le
spectacle est coécrit avec Arna Joyet et
François Rollin aussi un ivelinois
également c'est ça très local tout ça
ouais ouais c'est de deux ivlinois aussi
donc on est on joue ici à domicile voilà
Arnaud qui est qui est pas loin il
habite pas loin là à trrappe donc voilà
tout ça ça fait peu de frais de
déplacement c'est bien donc la grande
tournée après l'Européen qui a cartonné
quelles sont les prochaines dates tu
penses un peu t'arrêter ou tu continues
non là là il est pas question du tout du
tout de m'arrêter on c'est le début de
la tournée en fait Montini c'est la 4e
date de la tournée qui en comporte
90 donc ça va m'amener jusqu'à fin avril
avec un passage à Paris fin février au
Casino de Paris donc ça c'est pareil
c'est une salle dont je rêvais que je
vais avoir la chance de faire du 20 au
24 février et puis voilà on passe par la
Belgique par la Suisse et on fait des
des très belles salles voilà je
comprends toujours pas ce qui m'arrive
mais je cherche pas à comprendre je
prends al justement j'avais demandé ce
que tu penses déjà à l'après tourné
peut-être sur l'écriture d'un nouveau
spectacle des rôle peut-être ouais le
prochain spectacle pour l'instant c'est
pas une quelque chose que j'ai encore en
tête parce que effectivement je vais
essayer de de garder du temps pour
accepter des projets au cinéma et et à
la télé donc je vais sans doute faire un
peu moins de scène à la fin de la
tournée et puis me consacrer à l'image à
la caméra on va te laisser s répété
merci encore merci à vous à bientôt
voilà Arnaud samère qui a conquis la
salle une salle comble d'ailleurs après
son spectacle le comédien est allé à la
rencontre de ses fans inimontains Arnaud
sa mère comme toujours s'est rendu
disponible et accessible pour son public
alors si vous avez manqué Arnaud sa mère
à Montini et bien vous pourrez le
retrouver sur France 2 dès le samedi 6
octobre pour une nouvelle émission
d'humour intitulée ONDAR show